So memcache has a way of avoiding this problem and actually
has a couple of ways. And the first thing we are going to
about is called CAS, which basically stands for Check and Set. And
this basically makes two different it adds two commands to the protocol.
One is called gets and this takes a key. And this
is inside of get. And what this returns is, the value plus
what they call a unique. Which is basically just like a hash
of the value or a counter, it's, it's some value that's unique
specific to this, to this value in memcached.
And there's another command called cas, which takes
a key, a value, just like set would.
And also a unique and basically, the way this
function works is for the key that you're
setting. If the unique matches the unique that came
out of memcached, overwrite it with a value
and return, basically True. But if you don't pass
any unique, or the key isn't in the cache, or the
unique has changed. Don't set it and return False. So basically,
what this allows you to do is, it gives you these
two commands that prevents you from, from two people overriding the same
key in the cache. So if, if we have two app
servers. So if they both run this memcache.gets on a particular key
at the same time. You know, they'll get two return values.
They'll get the value, I'm going to call that v. And the unique,
we'll call that u. And the fun of these app servers
updates key. By calling cas, he wants to update key to
the variable stored in y, using the unique u. This will
succeed and it will return True. And if this guy tries
to do the same thing, only, memcache will only accept one
right at a time. It does it very, very fast but
it'll only do one right at a time. So if this
guy tries to run the exact same code, mc.cas. We are going to
set key to a variable sort of y, passing
in u. This one will return False. Because this,
this app server got there first. And, and of
the unique value stored in memcache changed. You know,
what both of these app servers would really do,
is that the, the code would look something like
this. You know r equals and then like while r equals False. You
have like, u, v equals mc.gets,
r equals mc.cas k, y, u. So you have this
loop where you basically, you know, get the new, get the
new unique out of the memcached and then try to
set it. And then once you're setting the unique that you
got out of memcached. Or that is the unique that's
stored in memcache now, matches the one that you got out,
you know, that you made the correct edit. Now, generally you
only use this when you're doing kind of a destructive operation
to the cache. Like you're updating a list. You know, if you're just over writing
something, you don't need to worry about it.
But if you're kind of manipulating an object
and the order of manipulation matters, you
can use something like cas. And so what
I'd like you to do is go ahead
and implement these functions in our fake memcached.